welcome back to new rockstars the
mandalorian season 2 opened with the
shocking
return of well a character whose return
was widely reported last may
a character lucasfilm confirmed was
still alive in a 2006 visual dictionary
and a character who called himself
indigestible by the sarlacc in the 1992
novel
boba fett is our head canon wet dream
resurrection gonna fight mando to the
death
or become a spirit guide with the best
war stories
well i'm eric voss this is rogue theory
the
show that brings you the wildest nerdy
hot takes on the topics that you
cannot stop talking about remember
remember the 5th of november to all of
our uk watchers
because this is november 5th though we
are currently shooting this one hour
before the polls close on election day
here in the united states uh here with
me today is the cop band of rochester
new york
tommy bechtold well hey there man
delorean ah yes good to be here very
excited i would say the most shocking
return to me
uh in mandalorian season two episode one
was my little brother who showed no
interest in star wars for like 25 years
uh announced to me that he was watching
the show so welcome back
welcome back to the star wars universe
buddy we missed you yeah we did
uh also with us is friend of the show
twitch streamer and host angelica trey
hi it's good to be back i hope
everyone's good
yes we're good for now we're good um but
uh also joining us we're thrilled to
welcome to rogue theory a host i
recently shared a rooster teeth gaming
panel with who thankfully did not point
out how little about gaming that i know
and chief of geeks of color dorian parks
welcome to new rockstars man
thank you guys so much for having me
watch you guys all the time so it means
a lot for you to just invite me on your
show this is awesome man
definitely definitely uh this is gonna
be a lot of fun i i love this
lineup this is this could be a fun panel
oh and uh before we begin
uh you may have noticed that i am once
again wearing uh my new favorite shirt
our custom
this is the way tea available at new
rockstar's new merch store
at new rockstarsmerch.com we got a ton
of great designs including there's a hi
i'm eric voss shirt if you want to walk
around with my name on you
some people are buying it you might like
it uh if you want to get the
this is a waist shirt though for a few
bucks more you can write in a custom
shout out
that we will feature in friday's
episodes of wikileaks
uh and we're selling out of those
quickly so you're going to want to jump
on it newrockstersmerch.com
that out of the way let's talk boba
folks in the final seconds of the
mandalorian season premiere boba fett
watched mando and baby yoda carefully as
they sped past the tatooine binary
sunset
and they were carrying his old green
armor
what should we make of his expression
are boba fett and mando
doomed to fight to the death or is there
a way
they can help each other this season i
want to hear your theories tommy
why don't you go first yes well you know
at times are tough
we are certainly at a very stressful
time uh
in our nation and people want peace
people want
uh brotherhood and human beings to come
together and unfortunately i don't think
that's gonna happen on the mandalorians
i think this is a death match i think
this is a fight to the death between
two scrappy boys that both like to wear
helmets
uh one has lost his helmet the uh and
the other one now has that man's helmet
here's what i think how this is gonna go
down
work with me here follow me on this
pathway uh this
is the way as i like to say uh so
boba fett has somehow found out that his
father jango fett actually was
a legitimate mandalorian like rather
than uh a
a band or or disc or or disgrace for not
being a true
mandalorian and that uh leads to both
kind of becoming fanatical about the
mandalorian
ways now he himself is a clone so he's
kind of like a little slice of
cheddar cheese off the bigger block the
mandalorian block if you will
so he's kind of like not cool even with
himself wearing the armor that's why he
sold his armor to the jaw was he's a bit
of a
of a of a purist in a disturbing way i
would say
so that's going to lead to him having a
real problem with uh
din jaron uh the mandalorian who is a
family
a self-proclaimed foundling and there's
nothing wrong with being a foundling
i've got a lot of foundlings in my life
i uh
you know i find friends everywhere but i
think that's gonna be a big problem with
boba fett
i think boba fett is gonna is gonna try
and get both his armor
and uh our mandalorian uh that we're
following in the show's armor
back through a fight i think he's gonna
be stalking him through the galaxy
the child will be there baby oda he'll
be there to make things float and
distract us but the real conflict is
going to be between these two
kind of uh people with with with ties to
the mandalorian uh people that are that
are a little more gray
than a direct descendants from
mandalorian ancestors
so that's my theory interesting theory
tommy and yeah you are
presenting the idea that i think we all
deep down want to see we want to see
these two fight we want to see
the galaxy's greatest bounty hunters uh
take each other down and i know a lot of
people when
the mandalorian was first announced i
think a lot of people were like oh so
this is a boba fett show
you know like they weren't totally clear
that's how like synonymous
uh mandalorian armor was with boba fett
back in those days and
uh so it'd be cool to see it it's like i
say eric
if you've got two action figures you've
got two choices you make them fight or
you make them kiss
and i would take either one i will take
both of them kissing or both of them
fighting but one or the other
it's got to happen or both could happen
yeah i was like why is this mutually
exclusive
kiss fighting is my favorite thing to do
it's really uh it's dangerous it's
frowned upon
certainly frowned upon that sounds
really dangerous actually
yeah there's there's some lines that are
getting crossed there one way or another
yes yes yes yes yeah i definitely want
to see them
fight i i want to see boba mano
face off i'm hoping sooner rather than
later i want to see it in this
next upcoming episode of the mandalorian
i think boba fett is now going to be
hunting bounty hunters i think boba fett
took um
fennec shand hostage and is
not going to like mando and there's
going to be a face-off there's going to
be a fight
in this next episode and as we saw
from the end of this first episode of
season two
is boba fett i don't think he like had
his armor taken away from him
i think he willingly gave it away and
it's like this symbolism
for him changing his lifestyle and his
ideologies and his goals and now he's
going
to be ridding the entire galaxy of
bounty hunters
interesting too many bounty hunters kind
of like
yeah the hunters like how cool is that
i always love that phrase like the
hunter is now being hunted
kind of thing if that can just be worked
in there in some way yeah
absolutely there's a movie trope right
like when they
see they see the scary monster and then
the thing that actually eats the scary
monster
it's like a nice shovel that is both
yeah and i think uh if anybody could
hunt down
uh mando it would be boba fett like i
if that's kind of the conflict there i
think that's interesting you bring up a
good point that that would be
uh it admit that boba fett would have to
voluntarily give up his armor i don't
think it was stolen from him and uh
to tommy's point earlier i i don't know
if he would sell the armor to the jaws
because if you are
precious about other people wearing it
you don't pawn it you know you you you
maybe throw it into a river and then
someone else pulls it up there aren't
any rivers on tattooing maybe you throw
it throw it away you bury it in the dune
sea
uh uh maybe the same spot where ray will
later bury a
um a lightsaber who knows if we're still
pretending that's uh
uh that happened but uh
but i'm rambling a lot here uh but i i
do think that would be interesting if
that's his prerogative
i don't want uh boba fett to be a a
passive character who is just sought
after
i want him to be on the offensive and if
and if he was indeed the one who picked
up fenix shand at the end of episode
five last season that would be part of
his mo right like i'm tired of these
freaking bounty hunters everywhere let's
stop
treating people like prizes to be uh
bountied
um but yeah yeah yeah um dorian what do
you think what do you think
is going to be the deal with mando and
so i personally think they're going to
actually team up although i do see them
fighting early on i could just all
ultimately see them teaming up and being
like you know what let's put our
differences aside
we got to take dom off gideon and so
it's like them to have a little
altercation early on and they're like no
we're not the best like we we're on the
same team right now especially
because he does have some familiarities
with the mandalore i feel like they'll
have more in common versus being like
you know like
we need to fight each other so i feel
like it's more of them teaming up and
then i
also because he is a clone i feel like
he'll have a little bit of connection
because it's going to go to my
theory for the next topic i feel like
he'll have a little bit of relationship
with baby yoda because
i think baby yoda's a clone so he'll
have some connection with that and he'll
be like
hey all right i see myself and him let
me let me get on this journey with them
and let me help them
find where they need to go with the jedi
so i kind of think that might happen but
i do like them i i do like what you said
angelica so i don't know
yeah no i think you bring up a good
point i think at the end of the day they
do have more to gain from working
together and
and i think the the biggest point uh the
counterpoint i would give
uh against like people who say they're
definitely gonna fight or that amanda
would want his armor back
is the fact that like the armor was just
sitting right over there in mos pelgo
for years right like at any point boba
fett could have just gone over there and
taken his armor back
he clearly doesn't want it anymore
anymore he clearly is like
okay with taking on a new chapter and if
he if he is as we kind of talked about
in other videos uh
maybe living with the tuscan raiders
like that kind of there is a parallelism
there right with
with with mando they're both kind of
people who just adopted the uh
the identity of the new tribe the new
the new clan they're with uh
so listen i i feel like it you you get
eaten by a star like that changes your
whole perspective on life you're like
you to take a step back and re-evaluate
every decision you made you're like you
know what
maybe i need to let me just take it let
me just i i made some choices let me
just go away
let me let me start fresh let me start
over so i feel like that's how he's
approaching your ryan now he's like you
know
i survived this he saw he saw spiritual
space jesus and he's like
it's time for a change yeah that just
reminded me of one of those like scenes
of maybe like the next episode of
mandalorian they'll just like snap to
boba fett's experience it'll be like a
record scratch
you may be wondering how i got here
[Laughter]
yeah i love that yes if that's yeah if
my last uh
path led me to that uh clearly i was
doing something wrong
yeah let's let's just turn the page yeah
uh great great
so for this first round for those three
theories all interesting takes and all
takes that i think
could end up being true i don't think
any of those are necessarily
mutually exclusive because years have
passed who knows what he's been doing
these past couple years
so i mean we're all getting a fight
right yeah we're asked for a fight
there better be a fight i mean every
every fight can lent
that no better way to form a friendship
than to take a swing at someone and they
take us
that's like me and you the first time we
met we got in a fist fight i can't wait
we got a kiss fight yeah that's that's
what happened um
all right so all three of you i'm gonna
award each of you one
point so all of you are on the board uh
and then
we'll see who's at the at the high score
at the end of the game but before we
continue uh we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
starting with our friends at
hellofresh hellofresh lets you skip
those strips to the grocery store and
makes home cooking easy fun and
affordable
hellofresh offers convenient no contact
delivery to your doorstep
for easy home cooking with the family
that can be up to 40 cheaper than
shopping at the grocery store hellofresh
offers more than 20 chef crafted
delicious options
every week to help you break out of your
recipe right try new things and make
every night feel special
even if the only thing you'll be doing
after dinner is bingeing the west wing
or firefly for the 100th time
on top of being delicious and convenient
hello fresh is the first global carbon
neutral meal kit company and their
packaging is almost entirely made from
recyclable or already recycled content
you know recycled content like
we do by putting avengers in game in the
title of every video
and my recent hello fresh delivery i i
got to try
firecracker meatballs as a florida boy
who has ingested several actual
firecrackers in my life i can say
that these meatballs tasted like tasty
gingery beef
and not like burning so give it a try
you're gonna love it
go to hellofresh.com rogue9090 and use
the code rogue90
to get 90 off including free shipping
again that's hellofresh.com
rogue90 and use the code rogue 90 to get
90
off including free shipping and after
you've had your hello fresh meal
where are you going to sleep that night
because you're going to need some rest
well
we also want to thank our friends at
helix sleep for helping us make this
episode
i'm a unique weirdo and i need a unique
mattress to fit my weird body and my
weird sleep habits and so
do you even if you're not weird well
thanks to our sponsor helix sleep
we can finally have a mattress that does
that helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses shipped straight to your door
with free no contact delivery free
returns and a 100 night sleep trial
helix made a two minute sleep quiz that
matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress just go to helixsleep.com
rogue theory take their sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
maybe like a firm mattress maybe you're
a back sleeper maybe you sleep really
hot
well with helix there's a specific
mattress for your
unique taste i took the quiz i was
matched to the helix mattress that
suited my side sleeping preferences to
a t because when i sleep i want to make
sure i'm turned away from tommy
who will not leave my bedroom it's so
comfortable eric i took the quiz too and
my answers were all
what's eric like i just want that i want
whatever eric
i'll have what he's having yeah
that's the last time i i travel with a
pillow that's exactly your height
body pillow yeah it's an eric size
pillow and i
i sleep with it uh okay in the very
literal sense i sleep next to it not
you know like a dog no we know what
you're doing with it
uh helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you are going
to love it helix is operating up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep dot com
slash rogue theory again that's helix
sleep.com
rogue theory for up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows
and finally we want to thank expressvpn
for sponsoring this episode expressvpn
lets you change your online location
so that you can control where you want
sites to think you're located you're
going to trick them you're going to fool
all those internet sites and they're
never going to know where you are
because they shouldn't it's not their
business where you are
like let's say you have netflix but you
don't want to shell out the money for
some of these other streaming services
just to be able to watch shows and
movies that aren't available on the us
netflix
because they offer different you know
versions of content depending on where
you are which is
bs that doesn't make any sense uh rick
and morty star trek discovery uh
studio ghibli films they it's different
where you are
while expressvpn cuts straight through
that it lets you log into netflix as if
you are in one of the countries where
that content is available
without paying for another streaming
service you just open the app you select
from almost 100
different countries you tap one button
to connect and refresh a page to access
thousands of new shows and movies you
can stream in hd with no buffering or
lag
and it's compatible with all your
devices like phones tablets
smart tvs whatever you got not only does
it let you change your location it also
encrypts your data and it lets you surf
the web safely and
anonymously just go to expressvpn.com
rogue
to get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free expressvpn.com
rogue and uh before we move on to our
second topic a quick shout out to our
patron rich
powers who won this week's discord rogue
theory
uh uh we have a contest for our patron
only discord server
their pitch for how boba fett survived
the starlock pit featured some
flamethrower action and eating some
rotten sarlacc meat
yum that's way more exciting than me to
say he got
burped up i think that was my theory
that people like really that's the most
exciting thing you come up with i'm like
well
yeah i mean stomach acid's a real thing
okay um but yeah uh rich had some really
really cool thoughts and you can play
along in future rogue theory episodes
uh by becoming a patron just by going to
patreon.comrockstars and you can join
our discord from there
all right guys let's get back to uh the
mandalorian in the season 2 premiere
there was this line that uh
tommy and i found very interesting we're
talking about this from wikileaks uh
pelimoto told mando about baby yoda
quote if this thing ever divides or buds
i would gladly
pay for its offspring and it's such a
weird moment because like
her line was almost cut off by the pit
droids screwing around with the ship and
it was one of those things where like
they intentionally wrote that line and
they wanted you to kind of forget about
it for a second
by having this like stupid gag in the
background but it's also one of those
things that is going to be in the
previously on
of some future episodes i just know it
so i i want to hear from you guys about
this what
secrets about baby yoda's biology and uh
and its origin do you think
this line could be setting up for a
later episode this season
dorian what are your thoughts on this
see i could be reading into this a
little bit too much but i personally
think baby yoda is a clone she was
cloned at the camino facilities and
the reason why i think that is because
four i think a little bit foreshadowing
you don't
give us boba fett in the same episode
you mentioned that little line
like i think it all is going to tie
together by the end of the season it's
like like i said i feel like we're going
to
boba fett's going to meet the mandalore
meet jen they're going to
they're gonna meet each other then he's
gonna be like oh wait that's
that's a yoda i don't think i don't
think my boy yoda was getting it in i
don't think he was
i don't think my boy was out there
having having
some fun having a wild time so i
personally think he was cloned i mean i
don't think
he was having he was out there doing
what he needed to do in space so for me
i think he's a clone i do not see him
having like offsprings or having like
little baby yoda sisters or anything
like that and especially because disney
has also put too much money too much
focus on marketing this one baby or i
couldn't see them trying to
get us emotionally attached to another
little creature like there's not enough
room in my heart for more
baby yoda's at this point in time yeah
no i can only i can only get i i can't i
can't get it emotionally attached to
more than one like yeah
this baby o does it there's too many
baby things we got baby group baby yoga
too many
yeah i i totally agree uh we're gonna
start getting like multiplicity copy of
a copy you know
and then you're gonna get problematic
michael keaton at the end of it and
no one wants that but no i i totally
agree and
i i the only line that is driving me
nuts is from season one
where kahil was like oh he doesn't look
genetically engineered it's like well
then why are you giving us
a ton of other clues that cloning i feel
like there's going to be some kind of
like
interesting explanation and the only
thing
that i could see making sense there is
maybe if you look at the timeline since
baby yoda's 50 years old
like maybe baby yoda could have been
like the first clone or something like
that
right like he was clone prime or like
patient zero by the clone and then but
was able to get away but they were able
to uh
to ha like the kaminoans were able to
figure out that
technology and do it on jango fett and
that's how you got all the clone
troopers and stuff but
yeah he's got to be a clone that's
that's my gut feeling too is like
he's either going to be a clone or
kamino's involved with this somehow like
one
one of those uh options uh all right
angelica what do you think
okay so i think that the yoda species
isn't born so to speak but rather it's
like manifested from midichlorian rich
swamps
yeah okay so because we see
you know we're so used to associating
yoda
with like dagobah and like swamplands
what if we
have them like hatched from eggs from
these swamps
one not only because i really want to
see baby yoda hatch from an egg like i
want to see
just that imagery in my head it makes me
happy but also i think it makes a lot of
sense
and you know that would that would
connect everything
with the yoda species and how they're so
connected with this
you know this the force like this
telekinesis that they've described
through
throughout the mandalorian and also
that would explain why it's so precious
because probably these swamps
have gotten destroyed by war or like
imperial expansion
yeah so it makes them even more precious
and more of a commodity
and that explains this entire like goose
chase
oh interesting yeah and because i think
what you're kind of hinting at here is
no one wants to see
two adult yoda's no one wants that
we don't want that mental image i
apologize for giving you that mental
image
like uh i don't want to see it if they
are fuel yeah
so hopefully hopefully they are just
like it's some kind of natural phenomena
that
yeah there's just some egg that floats
up to the surface of a swamp
we're all good with it and then uh and
then when they die they die they don't
reproduce
and maybe that's what they're setting up
is like he's not gonna have an offspring
or a bud
this baby yoda's just gonna fade away
someday and then there will be some
other
you know that comes up in a swamp
somewhere
message that you mentioned i think they
said what was the next line
i don't think this thing is genetically
engineered they say yeah it's too ugly
very possible and yeah i don't think
dagobah is going to be
yoda's home planet you know i think a
lot of people would be disappointed
they're like wait that was just like
where he was taking refuge why would he
go to his home
but if but if the geography and the
topography matches his home planet it
would make sense for yoda to want to go
to some place that had
like a similar terrain to what he grew
up in because
he'd be most comfortable with that and
yoda seemed super comfortable on dagobah
when luke found him so
i could definitely see a swamp being an
origin um
all right uh tommy it's your turn what
do you think is happening here
well uh i have to divert from my friends
here because
i personally think not only are yoga or
yoda's
born via beautiful intercourse i think
that they are natural childbirths with
no
uh no uh what do they call epidurals or
anything like that
it's a very painful birth with these
ears because they are people don't know
they are bone rigid
on either side so that's like a a
checkerboard
coming out uh but i think that the
reason that yo
yoda is so mysterious is because what's
uh like
just like i said on the uh first epis or
second episode of wikileaks
what's better than one yoda uh eric it's
twins it's
twins there is another uh
i call this one baby yoda and i call
this one baby hell node
because it looks like we ordered this
one on wish uh this one looks uh correct
this one looks like it came from
somewhere far far away
a galaxy even i believe baby yoda is
part of a dyad in the force
and this is why he has the power to heal
much like
rey has the power to heal uh using a
forced dyad from his uh
his uh sibling uh a yaddle a baby yaddle
if you will uh baby yoda baby yadle
there will always be two yoda star wars
is obsessed with things coming in twos
right that's right
we have the skywalker twins we have
master and apprentice in the sith
we have uh two droids that are uh
basically the through line of the entire
uh
uh uh saga or those two droids that we
we kind of follow along
why not have two adorable baby yodas
that's what i'm saying isn't it feel
it's twice as nice with this sugar and
spice yeah i want
i just want a bunch of baby yodas around
me i just want to just
you know like like all those people with
the puppies i want that baby yodas
right and i just wanted to i just want
to go back and reiterate these were
conceived
through consensual beautiful intercourse
uh
there was no doubt in my mind anyway
uh we are just running across those
lines there are no more lines
half of that yeah it got weird at the
end
oh it did uh sorry we can just cut that
out we are
keeping it in the episode it is written
in stone at this point
because it's evidence i think now i
think it's not even the top 10 worst
thing i've said on this channel this
week so
it doesn't faze me uh what i do love
about i mean
no dyad of the force that is bringing in
a rise of skywalker
uh edition that's interesting but i mean
there is
some truth to it right they force
healing is a new thing
in the star wars universe that came up
in just like episode seven of the
mandalorian and then it came up in the
rise of skywalker and then i think
recently
in a book uh one of the star wars books
it was established that the reason why
they were able to force seal is because
they were a dyad so logically that would
mean that
baby yoda would be part of a dyad too so
there's got to be another out there and
why not a baby yadle
yeah you know i mean i could see them
being a diet but at the same time
like if you're a person that doesn't
read the book or something like i've
seen rise of smart walker but i'm like
what is a diet like somebody tell me
what a forced diet is
you know it's another opportunity for
them to record scratch
just like they did in angelica's idea
and be like
just so you're clear a giant is a uh
a unit of two opposing forces that
create one complete
power at the bottom
yeah see and if you're like the man and
i feel like the mandalorian does a good
job of like if you're just an
a casual fan like you don't need to like
have your like stuff
explained or talk to you so i i don't
know man
i totally agree dory and i think
currently what the mandalorian is doing
really well is like
yeah it's steering clear it's just kind
of telling its own western tale that
every once in a while reaches back
and bringing and die out of the forest
on the mandalorian a lot of people would
be like
i thought we were done with that movie
um so here's what we're gonna do i do
like all theories tommy i'm gonna give
you one
uh point for your theory but i love
you're number one i love swamp babies so
uh angelica you're getting two
and then uh clone is where my heart is
going right now so dorian you're getting
two
whoa oh wow a real indictment of sex
positive baby yodas i gotta say
baby stronger they're 50
50 it's time it got really graphic there
for a second
i you know i you don't even realize how
much i held back on how graphic i wanted
to be that's what makes this awful
well i had draw i had schematics i had
drawings
i have 3d models i've spent hours on
this days it went from disney plus to
disney xbox
okay so it now comes to time for our
road question and you know what i don't
want anyone to hold back uh it is new
rockstars after dark at this point
and uh an honor uh oh so here's the deal
we got one very question
you're each gonna answer it anybody can
go first here is a question
in honor of the passing of the iconic
actor sean
connery maybe rest in peace the first
bond actor to deliver that shake and not
stirred catchphrase
i would like each of you to please
deliver your overly specific drink order
in the style of bonds martini order you
know
i probably get just because i've been i
re-watched the big lebowski recently so
you know i probably get
a white russian teleport two ounces of
vodka slowly so make a big scene about
it then once we get to the kahlua you
know i'll just be like
hold it pause all right now go then
pause
now go pour the cool and make it like 10
seconds work and then
as she adds a splash of cream i asked
him to bring out a firecracker
you know just make a real spectacular
she does that she
pours the heavy spatula clean the fire
the firecracker goes off
and i say shaken not stirred and then i
drink
cinnamon very nice cinematic as hell
um bartender
i would like one of those pina colada
drinks with all the
you know the coconut flavored ones with
the
tiny pieces of fruit in there and also a
little umbrella on top
shaken not stirred yeah yes
i don't know what to do with my face no
that's good that was perfect
nailed it i think it's waking the whole
time okay
uh mine would be uh hello there
this is a very crowded bar ah
my name is sean i uh i'm also a
bartender
can i have a ramen coke is mike working
tonight
mike's a friend of mine he usually
doesn't charge me and he gives me a
little extra liquor
it's okay if mike's not working no
worries brother
ah yes uh but yeah could you pour a
little more rum in that for me
yes and a little less coke a little more
have you seen the mandalorian
do you think that yoda was born by
intercourse or do you think he was a
clone
i think it was definitely yoda and yoda
intercourse
shaken not stirred all of that
all of that shaken not stirred i think
we are shaken
after that impression tommy well done so
tommy i'm going to give you the point
here but that makes
uh all three of you uh thai winners
today we don't need tie breakers here
because then and here everyone can be a
winner we don't believe in winners and
losers here at new rock
so well done to all three of you that is
it for this episode of rogue theory
thank you so much to our guests dorian
parks angelica trey
tommy beck told you guys were all
fantastic this week we learned a lot
about the mandalorian we're so excited
to catch uh
the next episode coming well later
tonight and then uh
tommy and i will be on the channel
tomorrow to break it down with uh
wikileaks with my
uh easter egg breakdown coming out the
next day um
follow all three of these wonderful
people on their uh respective social
medias they're all working on amazing
stuff that you're going to want to check
out
um don't forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast feed stay tuned to
this youtube channel for this and other
shows
follow us on twitter at new rockstars
follow me at eavos
see ya next time and uh now let's go see
if we still have a country
[Music]
you